well how often do you see very you know
the production value is an excellent
maybe even over produce films but the
story is just so poor whereas on the
flip side you'll see something that's
Tim handheld camera but it's a really
solid story even in five minutes do you
see a lot of that or or is it kind of a
mixture on Bashar make sure you see you
see if you see the lot I mean you do see
and it's tricky because it's some lower
for your stuff you know there's certain
value there you know they may be
filmmakers are aggressive the festival
and might come out and really support
and that's some way to consider we can't
stare and say we can we do or a festival
with still an event in business like
anything else we also want the best
product you can't out there compared to
what else you get so every year all the
films we have for comparing is each
other can't looking back a year before
the year before that it's about what we
have right now and what's the best of
what we have when we feel it's best that
we can show for this year alone now
looking at the back not the
future right now and yes you get some of
that you get these these films at a lot
of money spent and and yeah this is the
stories is lacking um there's a certain
I guess maybe it's a uh they just a
certain lack of care for for that
because I guess they feel like they have
so the other elements going forward or
which is kind of showing you spend all
this money and attention to click and do
all this stuff and if the film doesn't
have a story them you spend a lot of
money firm essentially kind of nothing
writing ok so you see that sometimes
it's kind of it could be that can be
frustrating that is kind of like because
you want to I something so much in the
odds that's that's not working in the
opposite you can appreciate someone make
it something really really interesting
and cool or very well developed fun
short or really good short that's done
with you know no money you know there's
something receptor that so yeah you see
both sides and you wanted you don't want
it but do you want to judge too much
based on all that you know because it
can be sort of unfair i wanna look at a
film saleable they any money and they
did source more with it than this guy
that wants money they just wasted you
know it's not everyone's still say
enough to make a certain project there's
slow process in place I want to under
overvalue England's process and just
assume that oh they had no money so this
is so much better in this one had they
had awesome money so they have that easy
there's still process day to get that
money they're still prostate and make
the
it's easy to sit and say all these guys
at this money then I just you know they
just they're lazy and it is it's that's
not fair and it's not necessarily true
um because we have discussions I go this
you know movie that has all this money
spaniel ago well they didn't work in his
level so you know you kind of an inkling
to like to like be a little harsher but
it's not necessary fairy I want to do
that too much and same with the film
that has no money the flipping me said
flips like we said you can say well they
have no money but they also didn't raise
the money they also uh maybe could have
they maybe they do maybe scared to make
that kind of film there's there's so
many things you can really discuss on
that front but the bottom line is we
don't know anything about that stuff so
we get too much into that and you're
judging based on stuff you don't even
know about you guys stay away from that
cuz I'll go back to like what is the
movie do you like the film is a fit the
program and it kind of keep it simpler
and go back to that because if you get
into too much of this here saying kind
of like thinking too much about what it
could be I don't know anything about
that stuff we don't know these people we
don't know anything about that real
history of their film how the film came
to be so to start assuming that stuff I
don't think it's really unfair so does
something we have to do always kind of
have to kind of guard against and think
about the discussions are hat you know
it's definitely we definitely have
discussions
you